this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
in the first part of this series i
pointed out some issues i had with the
material from pacing to some short
instances where it felt like it lacked a
focused direction that was before it
unequivocally wouldn't be over through
the level of care and passion kishimoto
clearly demonstrated for the character
of naruto and the wider world he
inhabits from that point on i knew this
story had something to it something i
didn't expect to see and going into this
second arc i was optimistic but
concerned that it wouldn't live up to
the climax of the previous installment
that i had seen the very best kishimoto
had to offer and that now it would
either be more of the same or experience
a slight decline
little did i know i was about to read an
arc that would exceed any and every
expectation i've had for this series
so far
naruto seems to be full of surprises
[Applause]
[Music]
this arc was phenomenal taking the vast
majority of criticisms from my first
video and turning them on their heads to
make one of the most competently
well-written arcs i've digested in a
long time funny thrilling philosophical
and stunningly depicted the children
exams are a monument to what kishimoto
can do and i can't wait to discuss what
i thought worked so damn well and one or
two areas where i was a little unsure
right from the get-go of this arc it
wastes no time at all establishing what
the goals of our main trio will be and
what the goal of the arc is where i felt
the first axe prologue was weighed down
by its establishing of these characters
causing it to feel a little rough around
the edges this arc by comparison is a
finely polished gem utilizing all the
pre-existing relationships we're
familiar with to bolster the motivations
of the characters in this story being
told here naruto still wants to prove
himself and to become the next hokage
and now he has the chance to achieve the
level of journeyman ninja the same level
as iruka his only father figure and one
that throughout this arc makes it clear
that he believes that naruto and ko are
not ready and confronts kashi about this
directly it's cute and it adds more
drama going into the exams for us and
makes us ask the question what will
these exams be like sasuke's motivation
is in comparison a lot more simple or at
least it is early on he's sick of going
on meaningless nothing missions that
don't push his abilities from the very
beginning his characters had one express
motivation to avenge his family and this
arc explores that facet of his character
in much greater detail than the first
did as he expresses excitement over
finally getting a chance to test his
abilities against worthy adversaries the
results are some of the most shocking
moments in this series so far however
for me the best part about these
pre-exam build ups has to be the
indication we get of something
meaningful finally happening to the
character of sakura one of the biggest
issues i personally found with her
character was that at least compared to
the other characters she didn't really
have much depth she felt less like a
character and more like a useful
mechanism in the story to create either
tension between characters or to insert
comedy and while those attributes are
important in a story they don't make a
great character in my mind and so the
choice to give her plenty of
characterization in the lead-up to the
exams was exactly what i thought she
needed this feeling of being less than
being left out and not having the belief
in herself to press onward to have the
courage to fail for me this injection of
doubt and conflict in her mind not only
made sense given her company and what
she has done or not done but also
because it gave her the chance to rally
herself right before the application
process ended it helped me build a
relationship with her as a character
which was exactly where i thought she
was lacking and now as this trio marches
confidently into an exam many see as far
above their current level we begin this
story and the characters we meet along
the way are what make this as magical
and intense a tale as it ultimately
becomes
so i guess it's time to start the tune
in preliminary exams within the story
there are three preliminary exams
followed by the finals dozens and dozens
of cell groups enter and only a handful
of participants will make it past these
prelims i've seen many tournament or
exam arcs in my day but none like this
there's an element to this that really
makes it stand out and i plan on
addressing it as i go so let's start
with the first test
[Music]
the written exam as soon as i gathered
that the focus of this arc would be an
exam where students and future prospects
would face each other in what i assumed
at the time would be hand-to-hand combat
for the chances of promotion i got
extremely excited i've made it clear in
the past that some of my favorite
storytelling devices or settings are
these which follow a predetermined and
easily understood format tournaments and
exams all offer wonderful moments for
characterization to lead the charge on
top of offering numerous wonderful
chances to get to know new characters
and given that kishimoto was a massive
fan of akira toriyama's dragon ball i
wasn't surprised in the slightest that
just like his idol kishimoto's second
act ii featured a similar format focused
on progressing to later rounds however
what i wasn't anticipating was the
creative approach he took numerous
stories and series wrestle the laurels
of the examine tournament format relying
on it to carry the majority of the
creative weight while they focus on
characterization there's nothing wrong
with this approach and many have used it
effectively dragon ball was one of the
earliest adopters of this format and in
being such was quite straightforward and
by the books in its approach however
when i saw that kishimoto wrote the
first part of this exam to be a written
paper test i was completely taken off
guard in fact i think i laughed out loud
when faced with the concept initially
the idea that he would attempt to make
entertaining something as mundane and
visually boring as writing felt not only
like narrative suicide but also grabbed
my attention the same way a train wreck
might different series have made writing
compelling in the past like death note
but i couldn't see something like that
working for a story like naruto at paper
tests just seemed like a bad idea but i
could not have been more wrong slowly i
started to understand not only was this
going to work as an interesting section
of the story but it was i think a genius
and unique utilization of this story's
particular strengths i'm specifically
referring to its premise and themes and
once i caught on to the fact that they
were being encouraged to cheat in order
to pass coupled with naruto's innate
inability to understand abstract
concepts at the best of times made not
only for a compelling set of humorous
and dramatic scenes but present what i
thought was one of the most brilliant
challenges possible for a ninja themed
exam i would never have thought of it
and something like this can only really
work in a story like this about ninja
training it's so damn good this exams
format follows in principle a very
similar path to that of the old
tenkaichi budokai's from early dragon
ball wherein the preliminary matches
before the main course set up the
rivalries establish the villains and
other main characters that will
participate later while at this stage in
the early 2000s that particular format
was somewhat tired and done this
innovation on those principles in this
new setting offered all the same
benefits in a new way i've never
experienced in the last video i never
understood the love some people had for
the character of sakura but with the
introduction of these written exams my
opinion on her completely changed in
addition to helping establish new
characters like gada hinata and lee it
also made me do a 180 on the character
of sakura with her intelligence on full
display proving to us that she's more
intelligent than even sasuke carving out
her own little niche in the group ending
on a thunderously powerful philosophical
note where the examiner does the
unthinkable he presents the class with a
dilemma either take question 10 get it
wrong and fail or bail now and try again
next year apart from this once again
taking me off guard with its immediate
high stakes the philosophy that came
from and not only once again felt
appropriate for the themes and setting
up this world but again highlighted all
the strengths of the naruto character
himself the character that looked the
worst during this written portion ended
it with the most promise by proving
himself in a different way and so taking
a step back to appreciate everything
this section achieved these prelims both
right before and after successfully
highlighted the main antagonists
established the strengths and weaknesses
of the main characters and got me so
damn excited for what was to come i've
read every dragon ball tournament the
hunter exams of hunter hunter and the
opening arcs of my hero academia but
none came even remotely close to the
level of efficiency and creativity these
chapters impressed me with major kudos
to kishimoto for this section it's no
small feat to take all the boxes the way
he's done here comfortably it is my
favorite part of the story so far
the forest of death the concept
surrounding this section was interesting
to say the least while less focused in
the prior and slightly more conventional
the opportunities this hunger
games-esque type format offered should
be clear there's a reason tv shows like
alice in borderlands and squid games
have become so popular in recent years
placing contestants into a battle royale
type setting vying for their lives has
limitless possibilities for drama comedy
and conflict all within creative and
seldom seen set pieces and this
challenge was no different however
funnily enough this was a challenge that
really helped me come to grips with some
of the more intense themes of the story
and at first i didn't completely
understand in the prior exam ibiki the
lead examiner for the written test said
before that test that and i quote from
this point there will be no more
fighting without the express permission
of the examining officer and even if
that permission is granted anything that
endangers another applicant's life is
strictly forbidden it seemed
straightforward enough i thought no
killing each other and as the remaining
kids signed the document waving this
rule of no killing my mind's immediate
first thought was that this must be a
bluff on behalf of the examiners to
create a high-stakes simulation for
their future young talents i thought
okay they each get one of two types of
scroll and must retrieve the second type
within the allotted time i immediately
thought an interesting concept would be
that they all had the same color scroll
and that those that managed to listen to
the prior rules outlined by ibiki would
survive while others would succumb to
the pressure and take more drastic and
drastic measures as time went on or
something like that there were countless
directions for it to go and it ended up
going in a direction i never saw coming
[Music]
in an effort to try and out think the
story i over thought the story while it
ended up delivering one of the most
straightforward blows that shook me to
my very core i should put this on a
shirt at this point for how frequently i
say it but placing characters under
pressure is a great mechanism to help
build a relationship between your
characters and the audience reading or
watching everything that transpires in
moments of high stress and high stakes
feels authentic it can make a bad
character feel more evil and a good
character feel more righteous and in
these high pressure scenarios kishimoto
reveals that the person attacking the
group of sakura naruto and sasuke is a
murderer it's a chilling revelation that
suddenly changes the entire vibe of the
exam someone by the name of orochimaru
has stolen the face of an examinee
killing them in the process identity
theft is not a joke jim he's someone of
tremendous danger and one far above the
likes of naruto and sasuke in skill
orichimaru is unlike any of the other
characters i've encountered in this
series in the same way zoro felt when he
first tangled with mihawk back on the
barrattier i felt like this encounter
was equally as unexpected and
demonstrated an enormous gap in ability
between the characters there's a
tremendous amount of emphasis placed on
sasuke as he's the target of orochimaru
due to his lineage but for me the
highlight of this section has to be
sakura once orochimaru leaves his mark
on sasuke reveals that he knows more
than he's letting on concerning his past
and places sakura in a situation that
actually made me feel so much sympathy
for her i was left a little stunned
within a single chapter kishimoto
flipped the script on this entire exam
downing both naruto and sasuke thus
placing a tremendous amount of pressure
on sakura with no one to rely on
exhausted from lack of sleep and
terrified of everything around her for
fear of what might happen to sasuke and
naruto she stays by their side as
vigilant as she can be it's an
incredibly endearing set of scenes that
demonstrate her strengths brilliantly
when the cards were down and she needed
to protect her friends she without
hesitation was willing to place her life
on the line for them even when she knows
that she's going to live
what begins is a brilliant sequence of
scenes dedicated to the struggle and
tenacity of sakura builds up into a
fight for survival incorporating a host
of different characters revealing their
backgrounds and motivations for better
or worse lee remains to be one of the
best boys and most likeable characters
in this series fighting with his heart
on his sleeve god bless him and i can't
help but admit that i see a little too
much of myself in him at times and while
brave his participation is one that
stayed with me for the longest time
during the force of death sequence
drawing distinct and obvious parallels
to the character of naruto in his
admiration for sakura and his
determination to improve and save those
that need him
sasuke in this sequence appears more
vulnerable than ever before there's a
terrifying collection of scenes where
something horrific is awoken within
sasuke feeding off his desire for
revenge apart from looking very
impressive both in the anime and the
manga this section impressed upon me
something i hadn't considered before
another contrast sasuke provides naruto
specifically in this series where naruto
has had a demon sealed away inside him
without his consent and chosen to fight
against it to make it his own sasuke has
been given one specifically because of
his goals and actions naruto's goals
fight to free him from his prison and
sasukes serve to become his undoing
unlike naruto who wants to be the best
he can be sasuke specifically is more
and more over the course of this story
becoming more and more consumed both
figuratively and literally by his desire
to kill his brother and so while this is
just speculation if he is to fulfill his
role in the story to contrast naruto it
stands to reason that the closer naruto
gets to realizing his goal sasuke will
become more and more consumed by his
it's a remarkably interesting dynamic
and i can't wait to see how it plays out
[Music]
characterization is terrifying and in
this scene he single-handedly crushes my
prediction that killing would be off
limits what a messed up exam overall
taking into consideration the final
segment of these force of death hunger
scroll tag games the vibe i'm left with
is one of hope that leaves me with a
chill in my spine we met and came to
know so many wonderful characters in
these challenges saw each and every one
of the main trio experience hardship
only to rise to the occasion and
overcome some more so than others and it
helped to establish in a rather
mysterious fashion the most intimidating
villain of the series continuing the
trends from the previous written exam
while this one was much longer it wasn't
in any way less creative or
action-packed in my opinion these tuning
exams thus far have been an absolute
treat and have given me everything i
love from the traditional shonen format
action comedy heart and even tenderness
through irika at the end as he welcomes
his adoptive kid brother into his own
leagues of journeyman ninjas there's a
palpable sense of love between these two
characters and a wonderful sense of
progression to boot i loved this section
and overall with this force of death
sequence was an adventure as a quick
aside something i want to keep my eye on
is the examiner anko that encountered
orochimaru and got his sign on her neck
she seems to have gone through the same
metamorphosis as sasuke's so let's see
how this progresses with her down the
line
manscaped is taking off their new out of
this world experience with the
performance package 4.0 is now available
not just in the usa but also now canada
the uk across europe australia south
africa and even singapore wherever you
are the right tools for your family
jewels are now available this package
comes with a bunch of handy tools for
your own package and first scheduled for
liftoff is the new lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
you've heard me talk about its skin safe
blades and waterproof build quality but
did you know it also has a built-in led
spotlight to help you navigate the
treacherous black hole of uranus and
that's not all the bundle now includes
their weed whacker nose and ear trimmer
this baby packs a whopping 9000 rpm
motor powered 360 dual blade system
whatever that means ready to rock it up
the dark side of your hole for a
pristine trim you definitely can't
forget the crop preserver ball deodorant
and crop reviver either got to help your
little planet stay nice and fresh as you
continue on your adventures and those
adventures can last a lifetime if you
enroll in their peak hygiene plan
replenishing your favorite products with
direct delivery straight to your door so
if you're ready to abort hairy balls and
buzz lightyear that woody with manscaped
head over to manscape.com and use coupon
code not mark 20 to get twenty percent
off free shipping and two free gifts
your balls will thank you
[Music]
foreign
this changes everything i felt about the
story of naruto and took what was i
thought a more kid-friendly world and
plunged it into a much more dark screwed
up and politically driven universe which
isn't a bad thing at all if anything
this creates a nice contrast with the
plucky and upbeat persona of naruto
himself however it does bring to my
attention a few things worth mentioning
having children hunt and kill each other
is kinda screwed up even if for the sake
of argument i work to remove my humanity
from the equation and just look at this
scenario through the eyes of a
cold-blooded utilitarian it's such a
tremendous waste of future potential
that could make something of themselves
and serve their respective villages one
day i mean i made the joke earlier about
this force of death sequence being like
the hunger games but at least in that
book series people were selected for
that with only one person who
volunteered to be the standout of the
games themselves there's a tragic nature
to these events that paint shinobi as
tools of destruction conflict and
nothing more pawns for political gain in
my previous video i didn't touch on it
very much but the relationship between
haku and zabuza is very much in keeping
with this notion haku viewed himself as
a weapon to be used for the betterment
of the only person who cared for him and
zabuza too felt that way as a ninja
broadly speaking it's tragic it's
horrific and to hear the hokage of all
people speak so frankly about what they
are fighting for while interesting is
really unsettling in a lot of ways
effectively speaking confidently and
candidly to the remaining successful and
talented contestants about how
disposable they are in this world events
like the force of death where they weed
out the weaker ones is normal adding a
much more sinister tone to the likes of
anko who stated that she wanted to cut
the numbers down by half at least at the
very beginning and as we have that
horrific taste in our mouths concerning
the lack of humanity it's time for the
tournament to further whittle down their
numbers there are some significantly
important matches and thrilling
spectacles to be certain but the
majority of them weren't too interesting
from a narrative point of view so i'll
only be sharing my thoughts concerning
what caught my attention
sasuke vs yoroi
while short i thought this fight between
sasuke and yorui did everything he
needed to with the little it was given
but what makes this section interesting
isn't necessarily the fight itself but
the conversation that follows between
kakashi and orochimaru and just like the
hakage moments ago his words the arch
villain of the series so far echo his
exact sentiments concerning shinobi in a
sense that these people are expendable
and we're reminded of this towards the
end of yoroy's fight with sasuke as he
fights his curse and once again in chino
vs zaku a scene so powerfully punctuated
by orochimaru's one time lackey getting
his arms literally destroyed from the
inside out it's horrific and made all
the worse as we're given a fleeting
glimpse into the world of this young
man's history with orochimaru seconds
before this story has gone from strength
to strength when it comes to its
implementation of themes and pacing and
wild melancholic this scene is no
different
[Music]
sakura versus ino i never spoke about
eno earlier in this video despite her
being directly involved in a number of
scenarios but eno is another character
that gets some decent shine and
exposition here and a chance to show her
true colors from a foundational
perspective i enjoy her popular girl
demeanor and character design but just
like sakura in the last arc she suffers
from issues stemming from sasuke being a
massive driving force in her life
however and this is a big however she
does offer sakura a means to further
distance herself from this mindset again
i want to reiterate that really liking a
boy or someone in a story isn't a sin or
even a bad thing necessarily but what's
made me like sakura all the more lately
has been her ability to fight against
her demons and in the case of her
defense of sasuke her insecurities
fighting tooth and nail to protect those
she cared for all the while earning the
respect of those around her this was a
brilliant moment from the force of death
and it's one of the reasons why i found
this fight against ino to be so
incredibly frustrating not because it's
bad far from it it's amazing there's a
touching story filled with impactful
gestures symbolism and touching
character writing however there's also
this
now look i understand that in some cases
particularly for the purposes of
deception and espionage leaning into
some more feminine qualities or
embracing said qualities is important
for young female ninja prospects to be
able to wield that makes sense as a
concept but kishimoto i've found
whenever he tries to write a female
character like a female character he
does so in a fashion that convinces me
he's never seen or spoken to a woman
ever in his life there are some
brilliant visual metaphors demonstrating
sakura's flowering personality and her
independence like when she takes off her
headband emblematic of her taking off
the security blanket her one-time friend
ino gave her and that's brilliant but
throughout this chapter instead of these
two having a meaningful rivalry over
something philosophically profound or
substantial like the other fights i'm
constantly reminded that this is a
rivalry over sasuke's affection however
looking past that there's as i said so
much to like about this fight from its
strategic action set pieces all the way
to its terrific use of the way kishimoto
has depicted sakura since the beginning
with her inner sakura overriding ino's
control power it's such a brilliant and
creative idea and really while female
character writing isn't his strong suit
creative implementation of these
techniques certainly is and i'm
delighted this fight got some of that
too i'm a little bummed that it ended in
a tie but at the end of the day it's
still the best fight so far and i think
what i like about this section of the
ark really is how much emphasis it
places on the secondary and supporting
characters while naruto does pick up the
victory in his bout later on there's not
a tremendous amount that happens apart
from
[Music]
hinata versus nedji to be perfectly
honest of all the fights in this section
and trust me there's a balls to the wall
fight to end all fights in this section
in a second this fight first between
hinata and her cousin neji totally took
me off guard and turned out to be
incredible i had no idea the quiet girl
and this person i didn't know the name
of before would have one of the best
fights of the tournament there's a
palpable resentment with heaps of
political undertones broiling right
beneath the surface as nenji expresses
her resentment towards hinata's family
branch all the while hinata tries to
overcome her shortcomings and timid
nature to give nenji a far more
competitive bout than anyone ever
expected from her she's been one of the
only classmates of naruto to actually
show him some admiration and respect
when it's due and i like how this fight
has echoes of what made naruto special
because of that she's able to recognize
what makes him strong and all throughout
this arc she's sort of been the only
characters to believe in or care for him
and during this fight the dominoes fall
and i come to realize why she wants that
sort of self-belief for herself it's
easily one of the best fights and
kishimono does a terrific job of
characterizing hinata as someone of
interest funnily and ironically enough
in writing hinata kishimoto managed to
write a more compelling female character
than the likes of perhaps sakura and
certainly ino
[Music]
gada vs rock lee
oh my god before going into this fight
without knowing the source of these
names i had heard through the grapevine
that gara versus rockley was something
special i wasn't even 100 sure of which
anime it came from but
would this be a good one it was
mentioned during the force of death exam
that gara's sand abilities happen
without him needing to think and this
turns out to be the antithesis of rock
lee who had to work for every single
thing he ever achieved unlike gada he
wasn't born with this innate ability to
perform sand manipulation as if he were
a master of ultra instinct but the
initial back and forth between these two
fighters plays to the advantages this
setup provides too gada is set up to be
this immovable object this unbeatable
foe one that has never even had an
attack land on it and so early on we not
only see what gadda vs rockley is but
also the battling between two different
approaches to work natural born talent
and innate ability versus hard work for
earned power a tale as old as time
certainly and it's performed to
tremendous effect here a genius versus a
genius of hard work there's short
glimpses we get to see into lee's early
life that paint a very similar picture
to that of naruto's upbringing
surrounded by naysayers yelling at him
to quit reprimanding him for his
failings and insulting him for his lack
of natural ability when his master guy
walked up to him and called him a genius
of hard work i actually teared up a
little bit it's such a moving sentiment
that really captures the essence of this
character and in this fight rockley just
goes full blown [ __ ] kaioken this is
the coolest [ __ ] ever i haven't spoken
about this much as of yet but the
choreography and scope of this
particular fight is unlike anything i've
seen from this series to date there are
some absolutely breathtaking layouts and
the philosophical message brimming with
hope promise and determination is enough
to win my affections many many times
over and all of this is turned up to 11
in the anime's adaptation thankfully my
team gave me specific episodes they
deemed as must watch episodes before
i've recorded these reviews to get my
full experience and gara vs rockley is
remarkably well produced in the anime
particularly for the early 2000s with
its use of cg backgrounds if you happen
to have seen my attack on titan video aj
wrote some cool sections about one of
the earliest usages of 3d backgrounds in
conjunction with 2d animation to pull
off some insane sequences that inspired
the iconic action scene in that show and
it was this particular episode that
kicked things off directed by
toshiyukitsuru who i've been told is a
legendary name in this franchise this
episode switches things up by swapping
to 3d backgrounds which although haven't
aged well in places did allow for some
spectacularly ambitious sequences from
the likes of iconic animator norio
matsumoto it's all so dynamic and the
fact that this was possible on a tv
schedule back in the early 2000s is
astonishing turns out that it was
matsumoto who also animated the amazing
sequences in the force of death episode
i was told to watch and that was insane
i've been absolutely loving the
choreography in the manga so to see
these legendary staff members elevate
even further the material was really
cool aegis got me set up with all the
animation highlights for the future so
i'm definitely excited to see more here
for now back to the manga as wonderful
as gara is a dancing partner in this
instance to bring out the best of lee
it's lee's mentor guy that ends up
carrying the bulk of this bout's
emotional weight along with his lovable
precious protege you can see in his eyes
that what lee represents and is fighting
for matters greatly to him that he not
only can look on and enjoy the show but
is very much inspired by this young kid
too it's an outstandingly brilliant
fight easily the best i've seen so far
in the series and kishimoto managed to
achieve this level of personal emotional
involvement from me without using any of
his main characters utterly spectacular
stuff
this section of the story is largely set
up with it primarily providing us with
the chance to catch up with the plot
lines concerning orochimaru's plan to
steal away sasuke the history of the
fourth hokage and the various finalists
preparing in their own ways for their
respective upcoming final bouts in the
tuning exams this is all fun and
enjoyable but it's rather standard
however while reading through this
section i did find something worth
perhaps remarking upon a large portion
of this waiting phase is spent following
naruto's preparation to fight in these
final matches in these he trains with a
flamboyant mentor called jiraya who can
summon a giant frog it's humorous at
times despite the fan service however
what's interesting about this is what it
made me notice i've mentioned this
before but akira toriyama's dr slump and
dragon ball were massive influences on
kishimoto and naruto by extension and
nowhere was this more obvious to me than
with this specific scene
years back i wrote a series of videos
wherein i attempted to break down how i
understood certain characters in the
dragon ball series worked what made the
likes of vegeta piccolo frieza and many
others tick in a sense and in them i
pointed out that one of the most simple
and effective narrative mechanics
toriyama implemented was through the
character of son gohan highlighted
perfectly in this scene
[Applause]
[Music]
we're all familiar with gohan's hidden
reserves of strength only brought forth
through danger and it looks as though in
his admiration of dragon ball he created
in naruto a character with the
determination of goku but with the
mechanics of sun gohan couple that with
his color scheme toad hermit mentor and
it's not hard to see the similarities
with that of akira toriyama's early
material but where this scene a naruto
himself deviates as a character comes
moments after his throne in the case of
gohan his inner power was ill-defined
and left to occupy our minds as pure
speculation it never came from anywhere
other than him ironically he is more of
a claim to a chosen one-type power than
naruto does in this way in naruto's case
kishimono decided to depict a scene
inside naruto's mind where he confronts
his literal inner demon directly i
thought this was a really cool idea and
what i didn't think would happen it's
brief but even so it's full of character
naruto doing what he does best when he's
caught off guard act tough resulting in
the intimidating beast trapped within to
acquiesce and lend naruto the necessary
chakra to save his own and by extension
the fox spirits life it's definitely one
of the most interesting developments for
the naruto character thus far and i was
extremely excited to see where this one
went
i thought the purpose of this scene was
brilliant isolating what makes gara tick
as a person and just like i pointed out
with the likes of haku in the first arc
naruto seems to have a great emotional
maturity for these particular kinds of
lost toy characters empathizing with
their situation even in the case of gara
where he's saying some of the most
reprehensible stuff mirroring the main
character offering an example of him in
an alternate world through the likes of
a more unfortunate character that didn't
have positive figures in his life like
naruto did really serves to highlight
what makes him wonderful i mentioned
that naruto is a character that's
designed to sort of look better when
he's punching up fighting on the back
foot like gohan was effectively whenever
an opportunity presents itself to show
courage and this is a character that due
to naruto's intimate understanding of
what makes him tick knows the lengths of
how far he's willing to go naruto's been
a character that shows a brash bravado
in practically every encounter he's
participated in even up against the
nine-tailed fox spirit the reason he
feels comfortable in doing so is for a
myriad of reasons but one particularly
stands out in this case more often than
not he knows he's willing to push
himself farther than anyone because he
needs to but now he's met someone that's
just as willing to do that and suddenly
naruto starts to shake brilliant scenes
similar to sasuke in this sense this is
a villain that's tailor-made to make
naruto look amazing placing him on a
back foot we don't often see him perform
on and i can't wait to see this fight
now
tune in final exams i'm going to be
glancing over some of these fights in
the same way the manga did while there
were story reasons for one of them being
entirely skipped over narratively i
really did feel like all the emphasis
was on these two fights between naruto
and ninji and sasuke and garda both were
amazing for very different reasons and i
will be chatting about them in detail
but one fight i won't be covering that
much of will be shikamaru's he'll say it
himself it's not what anyone came to see
but with that said he had a decent
showing for a chapter r2 with some fun
and creative action sequences i really
liked his shadow speciality and its
implementation in this fight
specifically it's super fun and he's
super smart you're so smart i'm gonna
throw up hold up
[Music]
naruto vs nedji the climax of this fight
shows first hand to negi someone that
believes someone's fate is determined at
birth that you can change your fate all
of naruto's life he was told that he
would be nothing special that even if he
did have potential he was a cursed child
burdened with a fox spirit and right now
in this fight naruto uses this as a
strength i loved watching this fight and
honestly it might be the best naruto
fight thus far that i've seen kishimoto
has done a terrific job of providing
this young kid with a host of
interesting adversaries to fight and
bring out the very best in him i've
mentioned already why gara is a powerful
foil to naruto as he shares a similar
background but went a different
direction in his life but nedji on the
other hand instead of having a similar
upbringing channels a philosophy that
runs counter to narratives obsessed with
and convinced that everyone's fate is
predetermined that they are all hamsters
running on wheels against a tide that
none of them could possibly overcome or
overturn the exact opposite of naruto's
mindset and showing this orphan child
channel everything in his power to grab
the victory was powerfully cathartic
with him effectively using all of his
weak points and insecurities as
strengths against his opponent
and by the way when naruto erupts from
the floor with that massive uppercut to
take out the pompous nedji i actually
punched my fist to the sky and shouted
yes it's a brilliant fight and for the
first time this one time loner receives
the adulation of his peers once mocked
for who he was the determination he's
shown in the face of adversity has
delivered him the stage that he deserves
a victor's welcome the message of this
fight being believing in possibilities
can give you the power to change your
destiny what an empowering and uplifting
philosophy
[Music]
sasuke vs gara something i've noticed in
this manga particularly this week after
i had to read like nine volumes of them
is that there aren't really that many
full page spreads kishimoto's paneling
doesn't feel cluttered but he doesn't
often go all out with a full page spread
too often and that can be a strength as
seen in this fight here he really goes
out to make this feel like the spectacle
it deserves to be ever since the one
month training began sasuke has had a
question mark hanging over his head
after what he went through in the force
of death and the qualifiers immediately
thereafter when he eventually shows up
for this final showdown with gara we
learn that he's been training with
kakashi and the way the two of them are
revealed on the page has a terrific
sense of occasion thanks to kishimoto's
framing the fight in addition to that
gets a tremendous amount of shine too
and for all intents and purposes this is
sasuke's highlight reel with the very
creepiest from gara making itself known
to us as he slowly starts to lose his
mind i don't think it's an
understatement to say that this is an
incredibly important fight and just as
sasuke whips out what looks like to be
his big finishing move the ark takes a
turn for the worst
[Music]
this arc has been utterly spectacular
and has shown me tons of stuff both to
analyze and keep in mind moving forward
there's a massive political upswing in
this upcoming material i feel and a war
most likely it's going to be amazing and
if you don't want to miss my first
impressions and review of that material
don't forget to subscribe but until then
i've been totally not mark i'll see you
all next week and thank you so much for
watching
[Music]